welcome back I hope that exercise went
great now let's talk about another
important data store concept keys when
you store an entity in the data store
the data store will assign a key to it
this key uniquely identifies the entity
and it's used for many different
purposes there are two ways a key can be
generated let's take a look the first
one is when data store automatically
generates this key let's say we define
the profile kind with these properties
and inserted it for the first time in
this case the data store will
automatically assign a key value to it
the other way is that you specify what
is called a key name or ID in this case
data store will use that value to
generate the key this is a good
alternative when you have something that
is unique for each entity because you
can query data store for an entity based
on this value so it's easier to find but
observe that statement the key name ID
must be unique for all entities of that
kind for our profile kind that is
exactly the case because we have decided
to use the user ID to uniquely identify
each profile entity the value of having
user ID is the key name is that we can
retrieve the profile entity directly
using this value and remember since the
user object is the first parameter to
Cloud endpoints API methods it will
become a convenient way to get the
profile but we'll look more into this
later if you are familiar with
relational database modeling you
probably see that this is very similar
to the concept of a primary key there as
well as with datastore you have the
option of letting the database generate
a primary key or use a value of your
choice but now it's time for you to do
some work